[Music]
westworld season 1 is really ambitious
amidst all the cowboys and robots and
violence and sex the show explores
heavy themes of creation consciousness
free will
the plot jumps between timelines with
flashbacks and visions mixed with
mystery and metaphor
people turn out to be robots robots turn
out to be people and it's confusing as
all [ __ ] but there's cool ideas here
so let's work it out what happens in
westworld and what does it mean
the basic idea is that westworld is like
a theme park full of human-like robots
called hosts
people can pay to visit as guests and
live out a fantasy
in the park many just drink and have sex
and kill without consequence
the guns there shoot high-tech bullets
that hurt the robots but can't kill
humans
but there are also elaborate storylines
the guests can join in on
adventure romance and discovery across
the massive space of the park
it's like a huge open world video game
where rich wankers come to play
cowboy and it's all run behind the
scenes by a team of developers engineers
and executives in this facility called
the mesa hub
the control room monitors guests for
safety narrative develops new stories
manufacturing builds new hosts behavior
programs the hosts
and livestock endlessly repairs them
when the hosts get shot or killed they
come here to be patched up reset and put
back in the park
the hosts live in loops living the same
day over and over
saying the same scripted lines taking
guests on the same stories
being abused and killed for
entertainment
the hosts are meant to be mindless
machines but surprise
they start to become conscious people
season one follows a few plot lines at
once
there's ford's grand plan amidst a
corporate drama there's the host maeve
trying to escape
and the man in black searching for the
maze and there's dolores and william's
story which happens 30 years before the
other plotlines
to make sense of all this let's start at
the very beginning
about 35 years before the main story
westworld was started by
two men robert ford and arnold webber
they built robots so human-like that
they could pass the cheering test
but arnold didn't just want robots that
seemed smart
he wanted to make them truly conscious
to be thinking
feeling people he was into a theory
called the bicameral
mind designing his robots to hear their
programming as a voice in their head
arnold hoped that their own voice would
take over and the hosts would become
self-aware arnold originally imagined
this journey to consciousness as like
climbing a pyramid but he later saw it
as a journey
inward what he called a maze this symbol
is based on a real world native american
concept
one of the first hosts was dolores and
arnold had a special relationship with
her
arnold's son charlie had recently died
and arnold saw dolores as a sort of a
new child
one who would never die arnold had
secret conversations with dolores trying
to help her become conscious
we see these scenes throughout season
one and eventually dolores solved
arnold's maze she became conscious
so arnold wanted to stop the plans to
open the westworld park because it'd be
immoral to make conscious robots suffer
for entertainment
but arnold's partner ford didn't agree
that dolores was conscious
he wanted to open westworld anyway so
arnold tried to stop all this
with a massacre he took code from a bad
guy host they'd been designing called
wyatt and merged the character with
dolores arnold programmed her to go to
the town of escalante and to shoot down
the hosts
and to kill arnold ford would later
recreate arnold as the host bernard
bernard lowe is an anagram of arnold
webber
thus bernard but arnold's massacre was
a huge blow to the early west world ford
did open the park anyway but financially
early westworld was just getting by
it only survived thanks to money from an
investor
william so a few years after arnold died
and westworld
opened william visits the park with
logan
logan is the brother of juliet the woman
who william is engaged to marry
logan takes william to westworld as a
way to bond with his new brother-in-law
but it's also
a business thing because william and
logan are both high up executives in a
company called
delos which is thinking of increasing
its investment in the early west world
logan's been to westworld before he
plays it as a black hat enjoying
violence and sex
but william's a white hat more moral and
sensitive
at least at first william and logan go
on some story lines and they meet the
host dolores
dolores has been wiped and reset since
her awakening with arnold but she's
starting to remember
and become conscious again william sees
there's something special about her and
they fall in love
which creates conflict with logan who
treats it all as a game
when dolores is separated from william
he becomes brutal in his quest to find
her again
he starts to realize that deep down he
likes violence and power
beneath williams nice guy exterior he's
a violent monster
william gets rid of logan and somehow
discredits him so that william can take
over the company
delos and he uses that power to invest
in westworld
saving it from the financial crisis
caused by arnold's massacre
and william continues his search for
dolores
when he finally finds her she doesn't
recognize him because she's been wiped
and reset again
and this devastates william dolores was
his glimpse at love but something true
and real yet in the end she doesn't even
know him
it seems that this loss leads william to
think that the only meaning in westworld
or in the real world is to fight
and win william embraces a dark new
identity
as the man in black and for the next 30
years plays westworld with brutality
and violence in the real world william
keeps playing a good guy
with delos he's a titan of industry a
philanthropist a family man
he's married presumably to juliet and
has a daughter
emily but a year ago juliet apparently
committed suicide because
of william he was never violent outside
westworld but emily and juliet
knew his true nature so william lost his
wife
and his daughter rejected him and
instead of then
maybe trying to be less of a [ __ ]
william decided to test just how evil
he really was he went into westworld
found a random host family who happened
to be maeve and her daughter
and he killed them he committed a truly
evil act and william felt nothing
so this seems to confirm that deep down
william truly
is a monster but it also revealed
something else
when maeve lost her daughter she seemed
alive for a moment
and revealed to william the maze william
saw that
arnold decades ago left code and clues
in westworld which led to
some deeper meaning and this became
william's obsession
to find the final easter egg or quest in
this great video game
to find challenge real danger purpose
and to escape the grief and emptiness of
his real life
so throughout season 1 william follows
the maze
he finds the symbol in a scalp he's told
to go and find a snake which leads him
to armistice with a snake tattoo
who leads him to haunt wyatt which leads
him finally back to dolores
because dolores is wyatt in the sense
that wyatt was just a story idea that
got merged with dolores by arnold
in the end when dolores starts a
massacre william gets shot by a host
which excites him
because he's been looking for real
danger and challenge
but the maze he's been following all
this time disappoints him
because the maze isn't for him it's for
the hosts to gain consciousness
the maze is for dolores and maeve
so as it turns out dolores story with
young william and logan actually shows
two different timelines at once
notice how dolores keeps wandering off
on our own and having weird flashbacks
and visions
these scenes actually happen in the
present while her scenes with young
william happened 30 years ago
in the present she's retracing her steps
through the park remembering the past
taking a journey through the maze
towards consciousness
like amaze it's a twisted confusing
journey but she does
reach its center in the finale at
escalante dolores confronts william and
the suffering he's inflicted
she confronts ford and bernard and
remembers her killing of arnold
she recognizes that the bicameral voice
in her head was hers
all along dolores becomes conscious and
realizes the person who she
must become she takes up a gun and
kills ford beginning a massacre of
humans by hosts
this attack mirrors the escalante
massacre where dolores killed arnold
but this killing is by choice instead of
being programmed to act as wyatt
this time dolores chooses to be like
wyatt
she says this world no longer belongs to
humans it belongs to her
and the hosts she seems to want to wipe
out humanity
she says you will perish you will lie
with the rest of your kind in the dirt a
new god will
walk one that will never die this is
some serious skynet [ __ ]
in the season 2 trailer delores guns
down fleeing humans
she seems to be moving towards all-out
war between robots and man
and this is all part of ford's grand
plan
at the same time as dolores the host
maeve takes a different path to
consciousness
she works as the madam at a saloon but
she starts to have flashbacks of her
past life as a homesteader with a
daughter
she wakes up in the mesa hub and starts
to see the reality behind her fake
life she remembers westworld cleanup
crews in hazmat suits who some hosts
call
shades and she digs a bullet out of her
body to prove that her flashbacks are
real
her world is a lie and she's died
countless times
so maeve works with the livestock
technicians felix and sylvester
sylvester is kind of an [ __ ] but
felix is interested in host
consciousness
and he helps maeve understand how
westworld works
maeve forces these techs to help her
escape she gets them to rework her code
to make her smarter and to give her the
power to control
other hosts every host has an explosive
built into their spine that goes off if
they leave so maeve gets herself burned
in a fire so she can be rebuilt without
the explosive
in the finale maeve stages a great
escape
alongside hector and armistice these two
have been fighting in shoot-ups and
jailbreaks as part of their westworld
loops so they're the perfect sidekicks
for maeve
in the violence that follows for a while
this is bloody catharsis until maeve
finds out that her whole arc of
awakening and escape
was programmed from the start bernard
says that this isn't
even the first time that maeve has
awoken it's like that moment in matrix 2
when neo finds out his escape from the
matrix was part of the machine plan
all along the real reason maeve escaped
was cause ford
programmed her to to create a
distraction so the cold storage hosts
could escape and join dolores
massacre maeve's also programmed to
leave
westworld and infiltrate the mainland
but she refuses to follow this last
instruction
instead she stays to try and find her
host daughter
so in the end maeve does achieve real
consciousness and freedom
though most of her story is part of
ford's plan
so what is ford's plan and how does it
involve maeve dolores william and
arnold the show leaves the details vague
and some of what ford says
still seems to contradict what he does
but we can work out his goals
in the very beginning ford's beliefs
were opposite to arnold's
arnold thought the hosts should be
conscious and free he liked hosts more
than he liked people
but ford didn't believe in host
consciousness he believed in humans
his dream was to use the stories in the
westworld park to help make
humans better to grow and change but
over the years
ford saw that westworld wasn't making
humans better
it was a prison of our own sins where
people like logan and william would hurt
and kill
over and over ford came to believe that
humans can no longer change that our
evolution is
over he thinks arnold was right all
along and that it's the hosts who have
potential to grow
so throughout the season ford works to
correct his mistake
he helps the hosts become conscious he
gives them the reveries update so the
hosts can remember their past lives
he restores the town of escalante so
dolores can have her awakening with
william
he programs maeve to escape and
infiltrate which is a fake awakening but
it helps hosts become free
when teresa and charlotte from delos try
to take over westworld ford kills teresa
with bernard
and when elsie almost uncovers ford's
plans he has been not grab her though
there
are hints that elsie's still alive and
the reason ford does all this stuff
is not just to keep control ford is
protecting his plan to eventually
free the hosts he doesn't just let the
hosts out of the park
right away because ford believes that
suffering is an
important step to achieving
consciousness pain and loss
define the characters of westworld
bernard with charlie
maeve with her daughter dolores with her
father and ford with arnold
ford believes that pain and time will
make the hosts alive and that might be
why ford leads william
on his maze quest the suffering that
william causes is important to dolores
awakening and william is also a great
symbol of ford's belief that
humans are bad and unable to change that
humans
are the enemy ford seems to believe
that when hosts become conscious
there'll be war between them
and humanity like how early humans wiped
out the neanderthals
but now humans are the old obsolete
species
and hosts are the new people who will
violently replace humans
ford says he keeps hosts in the park so
that they'll understand their enemy
and become stronger than them ford's
final narrative
his grand plan all this time is about
the rise of conscious hosts
and their war with humanity that's why
ford gives dolores the freedom to attack
humans that's why ford programs mave to
escape
and infiltrate the human mainland that's
why the main human character in this
story
is the man in black someone who started
out as a decent guy
but proved to be hateful and empty
inside
so westworld ends with a really dark
message
it suggests that humans like the guests
the execs and especially william
are fundamentally bad and unable to
change
the oppressed hosts do achieve freedom
but not through the compassion of
arnold it's only through suffering and
through ford's cold manipulation that
the hosts are freed
and when they are free hosts like maeve
and dolores don't seem a whole lot
better than the humans they're replacing
dolores especially who once represented
the good in the world
now seems to be a murderous monster
herself
really the only glimmers of hope in this
show are like
felix and his little bird and maybe
bernard and elsie
but overall westworld is bleak like
black mirror and the handmaid's tale and
to some extent game of thrones
the show takes a long hard look at who
we are
and who are becoming and the
conclusion's not good
maybe there'll be more hope next season
maybe
samurai world will be nice but the title
of ford's last narrative and of season 2
episode 1
is journey into night there may be
more darkness before the dawn
if you want more videos on westworld
game of thrones and other shows
please subscribe to alt shift x press
the bell press the like and comment what
you'd like to see next
alt shift x is made possible by our
patrons
if you want updates early videos voting
live streams and more please
support on patreon.com slash alt shift x
thanks to patrons nazif mishra dervis
yenievsky stem stem el mono laura
hamilton
thad gutshall and candice cheers
you